less probably and camera operator on
entrance is the privilege of making a
story with the camera in front of some
of the best artists in the world reading
the best words that I've heard written
for a long time
my name's Shawn savage am the a camera
operator on dragon unit em Thrones were
started on game since 2010 while the
first scenes operated on long game
Thrones was some of the Nights Watch
leaving the tunnel to go north beyond
the wall I've contributed to every
episode since then over those eight
seasons the dragon unit and I've had the
privilege of shooting scenes like Battle
of Blackwater Bay the red waiting our
turn which is extraordinary and amazing
sequence followed by Bob and then
followed last year by the ice lake I
think by the end it'll be close on 73
episodes
some of the challenges that the
directors are thrown at us with their
ideas huge moves amongst ships and
castle walls and visual effects
requirements those technically have
challenges to our sort of limit I say
I think if you ask me what my favorite
scene over those eight years was it's
when Jon Snow is forced to the ground
and then trampled and this seemingly
immortal hero of ours looks like he's
close to the end something left miguel's
fortunately direct to put into the show
it wasn't entirely scripted like that
kid went to ground I stood over him and
these stunt guys piled in and we had a
sort of safe word where we could call it
off at any point we had to see that the
light closed up so on Kitts face and at
that point I desert kit to get off the
ground and stand up again and I think
you can see that it's it is true
struggle
blob was by far the biggest challenge in
the scale of it the organization and the
ambition Miguel had the attrition of
going into that situation every day
solidly for 23 days was a huge challenge
[Music]
the nature of the story of games realms
and the and the landscape its setting as
really thrown it at us with abandoned
sets because of floods Rock Falls snow
storms wind it wouldn't be gamma as if
these things didn't crop up not knowing
that I do end up during eight years on
the biggest Shan World down Thrones mean
absolutely fantastic because this is the
right time right place my level of
experience at the time was suited I
think to the show I put the right team
around me on the tracking unit so for me
it's been very lucky in certain ways but
you know it's I think meant to be to a
degree I feel sometimes and I've loved
it I think it'll be a legacy of mine
which you know carry forever hi everyone
its charlie HBO dropped another promo
for Game of Thrones season 8 mostly
hyping up the really big battles and all
the camerawork they've done and how the
show has changed from season 1 being
released soap opera looking with the
crazy crazy wigs to the season 8
episodes which are much much more
cinematic so they're gonna be doing
individual documentaries for each of the
episodes just like this they did the
same thing for season 7 I'll post as
much of it as possible but be sure to
subscribe to get everything if you're
brand new to the channel there's also
new giveaway stuff that I'll explain at
the end of the video he says that he's
worked on pretty much every single
episode of Game of Thrones as part of
their dragon unit so most of you
probably know about the different
filming units it used to just be the
dragon unit which is there a unit in the
wolf unit which is their b unit because
the show used to be so sprawling you
have Daenerys over in the east and all
that stuff happening you have the Starks
up in the north and you have all the
stuff happening at King's Landing there
were so many different things going on
in different locations in Europe because
like the stark Winterfell stuff would be
happening in Ireland than you have all
the dubrovnik stuff where they would
film all their king's landing scenes
then you have all the Daenerys stuff
that's happening in the East where they
would have to film somewhere else so
there was actually at one point where
they had four different camera units
starting with season three as all the
characters started to head in different
directions like everybody started to
break apart the star children scattered
to the four winds so they had a raven
unit which was sort of like their SI
unit for pickups and smaller stuff when
they get to season four they disbanded
that and just went back down to two
units then by season six they developed
another one called the white Walker unit
to shoot smaller scenes north of the
wall obviously as you guessed it white
Walker related most of the smaller brand
stuff north of the wall with the
three-eyed Raven in them trying to
escape after the night king found them
that's all white Walker unit stuff but
this guy Shaun Savage is the lead camera
guy for the Maine dragon unit so he did
camera work for all their biggest
episodes he talks about Blackwater
during season two the red wedding during
season three he talks about doing
Watchers on the wall during season four
hardhome during season five battled the
bastards during season six then beyond
the wall during season seven and
obviously going into season eight he
would have been the main camera guy for
their episode three big Battle of
Winterfell with the White Walkers they
will be doing special documentaries for
all the episodes like they did for
season six I think they may have even
done it during season five in season
four I think HBO did a better job of
promoting them during season seven so if
you liked all that stuff they'll be
doing that for each of the six episodes
but remember he talks about all the big
battle episodes and we're mostly focused
on episode three because that's the one
they've been hyping up and all the
season eight trailers so far are you up
on the battlements you have pod with
Brienne here on the line you have gray
worm in the unsullied you have all the
Dothraki the only thing that's missing
from a lot of these big battle scenes in
episode three or the Dragons Daenerys in
Jon Snow that's why everyone's calling
it the Game of Thrones Battle of Helm's
Deep episode so we're all really excited
about that but don't forget that miguel
Zapata directed two episodes during
season 8 episode 3 big battle that we
just talked about but also episode 5
implying that there'll be another maybe
smaller battle before the finale so of
course think about it in retrospect is
no surprise that they would go into
their final episode with a huge bang
whatever that battle winds up looking
like there was also a separate video
where Alan Taylor who's directed a whole
bunch of Game of Thrones episodes
especially
some of the bigger ones was talking
about the original Ned Stark execution
scene during season one it is funny that
we were very proud of ourselves for
doing this we thought we were being very
clever we thought this was revolutionary
television and we killed our main
character and then we started season two
we thought oh [ __ ] we've killed our main
character hi I'm Alan Taylor director of
this episode Baylor's episode 9 of
season 1 game of Thrones and this is
notes on a scene
the scene we're showing today is comes
at the end of the episode it's the
combination of several storylines you'll
see the shot we used is kind of strange
it tilts up into the sky for no apparent
reason and then tilts back down to show
the real scene and the stage first of
all it's charming by Game of Thrones
standards now because we haven't not
nearly enough extras here the most
telling thing is that shot was designed
to show us the awesome architecture of
the Sept of Baelor which is this sort of
dome-like structure that covers the
whole square that we only lost in post
so the shot remains but not the
structure my watching now I see just how
little money we had of the time but it's
I think it still packs on emotional so
he's mostly reminiscing about how small
the budget used to be and how they had
to work around a lot of big problems
like we don't have this giant crowd here
we only have this one big statue as
oreos trying to climb up in the crowd
this execution just a handful of extras
to make it seem like there were a lot of
people watching this compared to Circe's
walk of shame during season 5 or even
during season 7 episode 3 where you're
on is coming back to King's Landing to
give Cersei her gift he promised of the
sand snakes in Yara Greyjoy most of
these people are actually real human
being extras that are on set whereas
during season 1 they just had a couple
people and they filmed it from weird
angles to make it look like there was a
lot of people in that crowd so if you're
really bummed out that Game of Thrones
is ending and there aren't that many TV
shows that work on this scale that are
this epic remember that when HBO
announced the game of Thrones prequel
series which they're gonna start filming
this summer they said that it would be
on the same scale the game of Thrones
has been the last couple of years so
just because they're starting a new game
of Thrones TV show next year doesn't
mean that they're going back to the whig
fest that was season 1 just in terms of
scale and scope it's gonna feel very
similar to Game of Thrones the last
couple of seasons
obviously Westeros is going to be very
different because it'll be thousands of
years ago so they'll still be a lot of
familiar things like they'll be some of
the great houses still existing but
it'll be way before the Andals invaded
so they'll all largely be First Men even
though there were great houses back then
so once we learn a little bit more about
the prequel I will do videos about that
but they won't be filming until this
summer so it will be a little while
before we get details and probably the
end of the year before we get a really
big trailer for that if there are any
bonus videos that you guys want me to do
for the behind the scenes stuff or any
of the documentaries that they make for
the actual show the show behind the show
just let me know in the comments it's
actually funny to think about it that
way
making a really big show about making a
really big show but that just shows you
how popular and huge Game of Thrones has
become they'll be more Game of Thrones
posting later this week there's only a
couple weeks to go before the premieres
here so there is a new round of that
book giveaway I'll name a winner when I
post my new video all you have to do to
enter just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video click here to
rewatch the trailer a billion more times
and click here for all my night king
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you